[Musique]
le château de chémery que vous voyez
juste derrière moi a été construit à
partir du xiiie siècle et il a appartenu
à alain souchon jusqu'en 1981 et ensuite
axel fontaine l'a rachetée et depuis ils
leur tape petit à petit pour ça et
depuis trois ans il appelle des
bénévoles qui lui donne un coup de main
et aujourd'hui c'est le chantier de la
shoah
bonjour monsieur fontaine
vous avez un coup de main là vous avez
des gens dans votre château pour vous
aider aujourd'hui oui parce que depuis
trois ans on a mis en place un chantier
participatif
donc on a réussi à constituer une bonne
équipe je crois que tout le monde on a
tous plaisir à donner un petit coup de
main pour restaurer ce qu'on va dire cet
élément du patrimoine
moi je mets un point d'honneur à ce que
dans le la mise en place de ce chantier
qu'on soit dans la transmission des
savoir-faire on prend le temps de bien
faire les choses on ne le fait pas
forcément vite mais on le fait bien
l'architecte qui nous passe rien aux
crayères
qu'est ce que vous faites ici vous
pourquoi vous êtes là ébéniste c'est
vraiment la pièce est une erreur c'est
pas du tout mon truc bon j'ai aussi mary
taille de pierre depuis je suis à la
restauration et l'hôtellerie mais j'ai
jamais tu avais jamais travailler la
pierre au monde a réussi mais qu'est ce
qui vous plaît là dedans ah ben c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire
actuellement et puis restauré les
surtout les châteaux
l'ambiance est bonne il ya des bons des
bons camarades de travail puis on
apprend des techniques mais on a un
grand chef qui nous apprend bien ça puis
voilà sinon c'est juste que pour le
plaisir et puis ça permet de se dépense
un peu
comment vous avez entendu parler de ces
chantiers par mon fils mon fils vient
ici aussi samedi et puis
on a parlé quoi plus du peu pour
répondre c'est comme ça qu'il fait
partie de l'association
h en train d'apprendre encore donc la
bombe ont fait assaut couche ap legault
petit donc avant la couche finale à la
chaux grâce
parce qu'il plaît c'est d'apprendre des
choses nouvelles et puis d'attendre une
ambiance sympathique se rendent utiles
c'est vraiment agréable de rendre
service à quelqu'un qu'il est utile en
vaut la peine by après mm c'est mikel
quelqu'un qui n'est pas du métier oui
oui tu as le droit de revenir
poule à alors on a vu monsieur fontaine
que des bénévoles venez vous aidez nous
à les avoir à notre partenariat pour
vous aider je crois oui on a mis établi
un partenariat avec que la fondation
d'auteuil son apôtre fois les apprentis
d'auteuil pour mettre en place un
chantier école qui va commencer dès que
j'aurai obtenu le permis de construire
est
je pense l'avoir pour le mois de
décembre est le champion va commencer en
avril et comme vous aimez bien la
restauration des vieux bâtiments vous
avez acheté une tour à blois et ça ya 20
ans vous savez tout est en 99 on a
acheté la s'est porté acquéreur de la
tour beauvoir à blois c'est le plus
vieux monument de loi c'est la plus
vieille prison de france et c'est un
donjon de la fin du xième siècle dans
laquelle nous avons aménagé des cachots
doute est ce que je vous propose c'est
que vous allez vous changer et puis on
se retrouve là bas juste après d'accord
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est encore nous
là vous êtes dans le plus vieux monument
doit qu'on appelle la tour beauvoir
c'est un donjon de la fin du xième
siècle qui appartenait à l'époque au
seigneur de beauvoir qui avait un fief
qui allait donc de la tour jusqu'à la
loi
alors en la transformer en cachot
d'hôtes chaque cellule a une fonction la
première qu'on va voir c'est le cachot
pour les enfants donc à deux lits
simples la deuxième c'est le coin un
petit déjeuner kitschnette pour prendre
un repas la troisième c'est la salle
d'eau la quatrième c'est le coin
parentale avec un lit double la
cinquième ou on va dire que c'est la
seule prison de france qui est un coin
séjour puisque le
le cinquième cas chaussée un coin on
peut se reposer
quand vous êtes arrivé ici il n'y avait
rien pas d'eau pas d'électricité pas
d'eau pas d'électricité pas de raccords
tout à l'égout et donc combien ça vous a
coûté tout ça entre l'achat et la
restauration de ces retours le lâcha
nous a coûté quinze mille euros donc
c'est pas excessif
et la restauration on a investi
je crois qu'il 48 l'euro quand même con
con amorti justement à la location des
cachots alors on monte à la terrasse
[Musique]
on vient de monter 120 marche pour
profiter de la plus belle vue de voir
dans tout à fait oui on est sur la
terrasse une vue périphérique
360° avec devant nous le la ville
ancienne de blanc va dire derrière nous
c'était hors fortifications c'est rare
de la voir comme ça tout autour de nous
tout entièrement panoramique ou et on
est plus bas que la cathédrale
saint-louis là bas mais on n'a pas la
vue panoramique sur la cathédrale là ici
on a on a nos 360 degrés ceux qui
connaissent pas la tour on peut la
visiter tout week-end tout le week-end à
l'occasion des journées européennes du
patrimoine donc de 10h à 18h jusqu'à
dimanche soir merci nous avoir reçu dans
votre château et dans votre tour merci
aussi au revoir